-You have been banging the drum
on climate change,
I think, more than
a lot of people have.
Do you -- You know, you were
mentioning that, maybe,
there's this sort of
generational shift.
Do you feel like it's getting
through to older generations?
Do you feel like --
-Yeah.
I think what you're seeing --
You're seeing a real change
in public opinion.
There's two things
that are happening.
One is,
I think the debate over,
"is the climate warming?"
is gone, basically.
I mean, 15 of the hottest years
have been in the last 19 years.
Like, everyone gets it.
-Yeah.
-There's still this sort of
ridiculous thing
about, "Well,
are humans causing it?"
That's also receding
to the background.
The big question now
becomes one of prioritization.
I mean, there's lots of things
happening in the world.
There are lots of things
happening in this country.
There's a lot of challenges
and issues we face.
And one of the key questions is,
do we understand
this is the priority?
Is this something
that we sort of structure
and orient American policy
around?
That was the case
in the New Deal,
meeting the challenge
of the Great Depression.
It was the case of World War II.
It was the case for multiple
decades for the Cold War.
I mean, from administration
to administration,
the U.S. government both
domestically and internationally
oriented itself
around a singular challenge
which it saw
as defeating communism.
The question for us now is,
do we orient all of American
social policy, economic policy
towards this challenge or not?
-I'm very happy
when you take time
to talk about things like this.
Obviously, there was,
with the release
of the Barr memo
about the Mueller report --
And, again, we're still
waiting for the report.
But there was this criticism
that came from a lot
of different angles
that maybe the media
had focused too much
on what the Mueller report
was going to be
and what it was going to do.
How do you -- Looking back at
the last two years, do you --
Have you reflected back
on how you covered it all?
-Yeah. I think we all have.
I mean,
the biggest thing to me is,
a criminal and
counterintelligence
investigation
of the President of the
United States and his campaign
is big news in any universe
at any time.
-Right.
-One that ends up leading
to his campaign manager
going to jail.
And his personal lawyer
and fixer pleading guilty
to crimes is an enormous deal,
as well.
And the big thing that has
driven this from the beginning
and my feeling about the Mueller
report from the beginning is,
there are many unanswered
factual questions
about what happened that
we need to know the answer to.
And the coverage was a way
of trying to get
to the bottom of it,
which we are still not
at the bottom of.
And I think that's
entirely justified
through any journalistic lens.
-I want to show one last photo.
Because you've obviously been
in politics for a long time.
Is this '04?
-That's '04, yeah.
-And you were an organizer?
-I was like a canvasser,
field organizer
for an environmental group
that was knocking on doors
in support of John Kerry.
-There we go. Look at that.
When you walked up,
they were like,
"Look at this bespectacled guy.
This bespectacled guy
is going talk to me about
the environment. I know it."
-He's deeply, deeply concerned.
-Yeah.
They were like,
"This guy's not with the NRA."
-[ Laughs ]
-What did you find
knocking on doors?
-You know, I loved
that experience.
I would knock on doors. I'd get
other people to knock on doors.
And I think one of
the great things about it is,
when we talk about politics
from 30,000 feet up
or you have a TV show,
you have to sort of simplify,
put people in categories.
People are so weird.
-Yeah.
-Actual individual voters
are just irreducibly strange.
And the strangeness
of both people
and their political views
gets sort of smoothed out
when you talk about categories.
You know, like,
"Oh, this demographic
is going for this person."
But when you actually talk to
people, people have all sorts
of amazing combinations
of sensible ideas
combined with totally crazy
ideas right next to each other.
And you sort of remember
just how much of a human
enterprise democracy is.
-It's supposed to be nice.
-I mean, it is.
-I mean,
it's terrifying because --
-It's both terrifying
and inspiring.
-Yeah, we all know a few humans
where you'd be like,
"Oh, I'd rather not you, but..."
But I always appreciate
having you here.
Congrats on six years.
-It's great to be here. Thanks.